Luis receives a gift card
worth $25 to an online
retailer the sells digital
music and games.
Each song costs $0.89 and
each game costs $1.99.
He wants to buy at least 15
items with this card.
And then they want us to set
up a system of inequalities
that represents the scenario and
then identify the range of
possible purchases
using a graph.
So let's see if we
can do this.
So he's going to buy some
amount of games and some
amount of music.
So let's make those
our two variables.
Let's let x equal the
number of music, or
the amount of music.
And let's let y equal the amount
of games, or the number
of game units or whatever
you want to call it.
So we have the first constraint
here that the gift
card is worth $25.
So I'll underline, the gift
So the total amount he spends
on games and music combined
can be no more than $25.
So how much is he going
to spend on music?
Well each song costs $0.89.
So he's going to spend $0.89
times the number of songs he
buys on music.
Plus how much is he going
to spend on games?
Well each game is $1.99.
So he's going to spend
$1.99 times the
number of games he buys.
And that has to be less
than or equal to 25.
So that's our first
constraint.
And then the second constraint,
is that he wants
to buy at least 15 items
with his card.
So the number of songs plus the
number of games has to be
at least 15.
so x plus y has to be a greater
than or equal to 15.
And so just like that we have
our two constraints.
We've set up the system of
inequalities that represents
the scenario.
Now we need to identify the
range of possible purchases
using a graph.
And this is a pretty
straightforward graph to draw,
this one down here.
This one is the little less
straightforward, because it
doesn't have nice
round numbers.
We could round it off to say
this is 1x plus 2y, but
instead of doing that, let's
just take out a graphing
calculator and graph
it on that.
And actually before I graph it,
let me put it in y equals
mx plus b form, or slope
intercept form.
So the second one right here,
if we subtract x from both
sides, we get y is greater
than or equal to
negative x plus 15.
So that's the second equation.
This first equation, if we
subtract 0.89x from both
sides, we get 1.99y is equal
to negative 0.89x plus 25.
Sorry, that should be less than
or equal to, not equal
to, this is an inequality.
So negative 0.89x plus 25.
And then divide both
sides by 1.99.
And we get y is less than or
equal to, the calculator will
actually be useful for this, we
have negative 0.89 divided
by 1.99 is equal to negative
0.447 I think is pretty good.
Negative 0.447x plus
25 divided by 1.99.
So 25 divided by 1.99
is equal to 12.56.
Plus 12.56.
So that that blue constraint,
that we can't spend more than
$25, when we put it in slope
intercept, it turns into this
inequality.
And the second constraint, is
that he wants to buy at least
15 items, turns into
this inequality.
So let's graph the
two inqualities.
Or let's graph the lines
and think about
the region of overlap.
So if I have my calculator out,
I should have it in a
place where I can I look
at both graphs.
So let me to click on graph.
So this first one is
negative x plus 15.
And then press enter.
The second equation is negative
0.447x plus 12.56.
And now we're ready
to graph them.
And let's see what happens.
OK, so it's it looks like we're
a little bit out of the
range of where you would expect
to be hanging out here.
So let me change the range.
Let me go into the
positive range.
Which makes sense, because he
can only buy positive units of
things to begin with.
Let's make the minimum
x-value here zero.
Let's make the maximum
x-value here 20.
Let's make the x-scale 1.
The minimum y-value is 0.
He can't buy a negative
number of games.
Let's make y-max 20 and
y-scale is 1 and
now let's graph it.
There you go.
So we're sitting in the
positive quandrant.
So the first graph, this one on
the top right here, this is
the orange graph.
This is y is greater than or
equal to negative x plus 15.
And actually, even better, so
I can color it in, I'm going
to pause the video for a second
and try to copy and
paste this image so
I can color it in.
Hold on one second.
So I've pasted it in here so
I can actually draw on it.
So this first graph here, y is
greater than or equal to
negative x plus 15, this is this
top line, because it has
a higher y-intercept than
this other guy.
This guy is 12.6.
So let me color it in
that same color.
So it is that line
right there.
You can see it has slope
of negative 1.
So it's that line.
And we want to be greater than
or equal to that line.
So we want all of the values
of above that line,
including that line.
We could also be equal
to that line.
So it's everything
above that line.
Now this blue line, this is the
other one, it's this one
right here.
And we have to be less
than or equal to it.
And we can see it has
a slope less than 1.
Or a slope less negative
than 1.
It's actually a larger number.
But it's a less downward
sloping, and that's because
negative 0.44 as opposed
to negative 1.
And it has a lower
y-intercept.
And we want all the
values below it or
equal to that line.
So all of these values
over here.
Now, the area that overlaps
between these two constraints,
I'll do it in this yellow color,
is below the blue line,
including the blue line, and
above the red line, including
the red light.
So it's this area right here.
So any combination of games
and music that are in that
area will meet both of
his constraints.
And one thing you might want to
consider, since you can't
buy half a game or half a song,
it would only be kind of
the integer coordinates in this
region that would satisfy
his constraints.
So however many games, however
many songs this is and music
is, this would satisfy
his constraints.